uh hey we're going to want to do a
special Mojave Max shout out now to the
students and everybody over the Saint
Anthony of Padua School in Henderson
the Mojave Knox team had a great time
talking to those well-behaved
kindergarten first second and third
graders they all enjoyed it when the
robotics teacher Mr Boland was
transformed into a tortoise a great way
to teach them about the body parts of
tortoises but maybe even better the
thank you notes from Ms Cook's first
grade class we're going to make sure
these snapshots in super cuteness by Leo
Tyler
Claire
Benjamin
Gia
and Reagan live online the better for
sharing and not that I'm old or been
around for a long time but it turns out
that back when the teacher Ms cook was
in eighth grade A Certain bowtie TV guy
stopped by her school too
no pictures from back whenever that was
we're trying to keep the focus on Mojave
Max and everyone at the Saint Anthony of
Padua school you can still enter the
Mojave Max and Merchants contest at
mojavemax.com